この光の先に何があるのか
後輩・これいつのすか
俺は知りたい
後輩・カビ生えてますよ
この世界の頂点に
うぁっ、キモいキモいキモい…
この世界の果てに何が待っているかを
俺は知りたいんだよぉ
なぁ！
わかるかぁ？
わからんというのか、貴様
はっはっはっはっはｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
この世界の果てに何が待っているというのだ
神よ！
教えたまえ
はっはっはははｗｗｗｗ
ッフゥゥ
ミドリムシ
後輩：さすがにこれはやばい
飲んでぇ（去年のお茶を）
後輩：これいつのですか？だからいつの
飲んで！
後輩：いや・・・。
一口、一口。
イィエェイェイ・・・
イェェッヘッヘッヘヘwwww
後輩：めちゃめちゃ愉快になりますねwさすが
ウェェイアーォアーォイィー
クァーカァオクォキウィー
後輩：今もう３時っす
えぇっ
オヤズミナザアァイィ
っんっちょ
はぁ・・・
はぁっ
ずっと撮ってた、
ppppoyon!
あぁぁぁ
テトラポットのぼーってー
こんちゃ、あぃえぁおぉしぇっす　　　　（はじめしゃちょーです）
やってまいりました
ポケモンGO!!!!!!
えー
ブロフシシンジです。宜しくお願いします。
あんまり言ってないんですけども
ポケモンGO
本気でやってまして
ちょっと図鑑みるかい？
えと、図鑑を見た感じこんな感じです
捕まえた数139
見つけた数142!!!
国内で・・・
捕まる・・・
デジモンは・・・
えぇっと、142匹でございます
３匹でしっ
ポケモンが足りないと
その３匹が何かと言いますと
まずここです。
68番カイリキー
あと、プテラとカイリューがいないんです。
カイリューとカイリキーに関しては、
あの、まぁ
すげぇ蚊が多いな、今
ワンリキー
ん、ミニリュー
相棒にしたら飴玉が自然にたまるので、
まぁそこはなんとかなりたいところは
ある気がする
感は
否めない。
ただ、
ッッップテラよ
プテラよぉ
プテラがね、進化しないから
もう捕まえるしかないんですよ。
ボボヂェェネアヴァッシャ
どうしようかと言いますと
今回頑張ってね
俺はこの日のために
ポケモンGO
ラララーララ
10キロ卵を4つ！
準備しました
10キロ卵からなら
プテラが孵るかもしれない
あと100メートル動いたら
10キロ卵が4つ一気に割れるので
今日は、酔った勢いで
プテラが出るかどうかをね
まぁ試しつつ
プテラが出れば嬉しいなっていう
ろぉーがれす。（動画です。）
ラララー
というわけで、まずは
100メートル歩きましょう！
ドゥァ
っちょ
吐きそう...。
ブェエェエ
っお
(足音)
100メートル...、
頑張ろう。
おや？ってでた瞬間勝ちだからね。
ううぅぅうぅ
あぁっあぁっあぁっ…
100メートルこれするの？
ぁあっはぁん///
完全オレ、
魔物じゃん。
（後輩）ｗｗｗ
あ、やべ。消えた（冷静）
後輩：それで稼げますよ
本当にぃ？
ガチでミニリュー
普通に捕まえる
やぁぁ!
俺んちのまわりどうなってるの?
オーケー。
楽しげな音楽
はぁぁぁ・・・。
あっ!あっあっっあっ!
来た!来た!
というわけで、ついに来ました!ついに来ましたよ。10キロ卵4つ。
一気に割るやつ。
え～、さぁまずは一人目!